what I mainly felt watching the film and
I felt that all the way through was why
didn't we do this we would have had such
a big Galaxy Quest is the best Star Trek
movie what if aliens thought that
William Shatner was real a lot of Galaxy
Quest is the truth about Star Trek it
really does feel like a trek movie
because it has all the hallmarks of what
makes a trek movie work which is never
give up never surrender like you can
overcome sort of any problem patrick saw
it and was blown away by it
What did he say I love this film
Dean directed Galaxy Quest is a drama
the studio never quite understood the
tone of the movie this is what you did
that's not what we thought it was how
spur action was the iceberg was a little
contentious that was in and of itself
quite a challenge it was falling apart
there was a literal fire they cut all
these scenes to make it a kid-friendly
movie how dare you this is a Tim Allen
movie it's how what happened we believed
we were making a movie for everybody I
thought the movie was gonna be huge this
movie's gonna be a massive hit but it
wasn't it's about the fans Galaxy Quest
really was one of the first films that
celebrated the relationship that fans
have with these kind of stories getting
the call from Captain Kirk and he's
saying the enterprise is in trouble
and only you and your nerdy friends have
the information required to get the
enterprise out of the situation it's in
like that's the fantasy that we have
when you talk about the fans I just hear
you talking to me we're one of them what
is the value of this silly thing we all
do what movies are and how we do them
and why they're worth something and how
we can mock them all we want but
eventually we fall for it everything
happened exactly the way it was supposed
to
hey screen junkies click to learn how to
see the full documentary
you